Use unique wrapping materials like old maps, newspaper, kraft paper, cloth,...
...or even natural products like leaves or bark.
Decorate with ink stamps and nontraditional materials...
...like colorful yarn, lace, or bands of ribbon.
While we're on the subject of recycling,...
...old birch boxes make excellent gift boxes for smaller items...
...like jewelry, wallets, and of course, beauty products.
Use an empty canister from oatmeal or coffee,...
...or for smaller items, an old paper towel roll.
After placing your items inside,...
...wrap a layer or two of tissue paper or wrapping paper around the roll lengthwise.
Twist the ends and secure with a ribbon or a cute embellished hair tie.
Wrap your presents in one layer of brightly colored paper.
Then, cut out shapes and paste on top.
Happy Holidays!